Hello.
Welcome to today's episode on Rawkode Academy. I
wonder how many times I'm gonna mess that
up over the next week, but welcome.
Today, we are continuing
our journey with Rust.
We're gonna dive into one of Rust's more
unique features,
but also one of its most understood, especially
by me,
and problem domains when it comes to learning
Rust. So before we get started, a little
bit of housekeeping.
First and foremost, if you wanna chat, drop
as much comments as you want into
YouTube's comments. We will do our best to
get them on the screen. If you have
any questions, we'll do our best to answer
them. In general, just let us know how
you're getting on and how we can help.
If you're not watching live, the best place
to ask questions or join a conversation is
on the Discord. So that is available at
Rawkode.chat.
You can come in there, join anytime, and
ask any questions.
Also, since the rebrand to the Rawkode Academy,
we now have membership options available.
You can join for a very tiny, tiny,
tiny, tiny fee, and it just gets my
eternal gratitude and support. So thank you to
the members that have done that already.
Appreciate your support.
And, of course, if you don't wanna do
that, that's fine, but please subscribe and please
click the thumbs up button on the video.
This will help other people find this content.
And today's episode is really important because this
stuff is hard.
And because it's hard, I can't do this
alone. I am joined by my friend Anna.
Hey, Anna. How are you? Hi. I'm great.
How are you?
I'm very well. All the better for us
now being here covering this wonderful topic today.
Would you please do the honor of just
telling us who you are and please share
anything that you wish to with us and
the audience?
Gosh. I'm about a seven year Rust user
by now. Seven? So I've spent a lot
of years with the the Borrow Checker and
Lifetime. Still
get stumped sometime. Thankfully, the error messages are
good.
I live over in Victoria on the territory
in Canada.
This
is my dog over here.
For my work, I
basically create a toolkit that lets you write
Postgres extensions in Rust.
Awesome.
Yeah.
So you spent a lifetime learning lifetimes.
It it took me so long to hold
that in, but I'm I'm glad I got
it out.
I like it. So before I guess, I
mean, I can always just throw the the
the terminal up already, but why don't we
chat for just a little bit? Like,
Rust, I I don't think any other language
has this concept of a bottle checker and
lifetime. Is that right, or am I being
a little naive there?
I
think if you look at tooling that exists
in the C plus plus and C space
around static analysis,
a lot of them do very similar things
to what the Rust Borrowchecker
and Lifetime system give you.
Fundamentally, they they don't come with, like, clang,
though.
Okay.
And
you're gonna make this easy for me. Right?
I'm gonna try. I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna, like, stump you. I mean, I don't
often get worried except when I actually have
to show my own coding ability, in which
case I do get a little bit of
the fear. But I I I mean, I've
gotta say, I've been writing Rust now for,
I don't know, I I think nearly two
years and I I just seem to like
avoid
these these things as much as possible and
stick to writing really simple Rust code whenever
possible and that's worked really well for me.
I think in fact, I'd probably bug you
a lot now when I come across stuff
and I'm like, don't understand it. But I
mean, this stuff is
not exactly the I don't know. It's not
hard, but it's not easy either. Like I
think if you just
I'm hoping that if we just spend a
little bit of time and cover the parameters,
that this is just gonna click for me.
That's what I'm hoping. That's what I'm trying
to say. I'm hoping so too.
Know,
most of the Rust code I write is
extremely simple and, like, I call clone everywhere.
And it
you know, I feel shame sometimes, but, honestly,
it's not a big deal. Like, the the
cool thing about the Borrowchecker and Lifetime Systems
is they allow you to do a lot
of the deep subtle refinements that allow you
to process
terabytes
of code very quickly.
I've gotta be honest. I do I reach
for dot clone an awful lot in my
Rust code because I know it's just gonna
remove the error. And again, I'm I'm avoiding
having to learn that next thing that I
need to learn. Either that or if I
that's a lie. What I do first is
I add an ampersand, and if that doesn't
work, I do a clone.
And that is my entire knowledge of, like,
the borrow checker, really. I'm just like, oh,
is that gonna work? No. It's not gonna
work. And then it said they'll say, oh,
it doesn't implement copy. I'm like, why not?
And then I just try and no. It's
the oh, yeah. The clone doesn't work when
it doesn't implement copy.
And the ampersand doesn't work when it doesn't
implement something else. Anyway,
I am ruining
my description of this. We're gonna rely on
your knowledge for today. So When I'm writing
my Rust code, first I make it work,
which usually means throwing clone everywhere.
And then I make it right. And then
I worry about making it fast.
Well, I never have to ship code to
production because I'm a developer advocate, so I
don't care about the fast. But I would
definitely like to learn today how to make
my code at least a little bit more
right.
Yeah. Okay. Let's get my screen up. So
we're gonna start, and I think we'll probably
drift away from these relatively quickly and start
typing our own terrible Rust code. But the
Rustlings example are a really good way for
anyone watching that wants to learn a little
bit about Rust.
It has a whole bunch of exercises
that introduce you to some of the common
themes,
enums, functions, scenarios, modules, macros, etcetera. We're gonna
spend,
I don't know how long, but a little
bit of time on move semantics, and then
we'll dive into the other components of Rust
Odd ownership.
At least unless I've never looked at Rust
Rust You've never looked at Rust Odd. It's
because you've already got all the knowledge. Like
so yeah. Let's take a look at the
first example.
Like I said, I think we will veer
off and and type our own dot main
dot r s or or whatever and just
maybe run some code that way, but we'll
start with this. We'll see what I actually
don't know what it's gonna try and teach
us. I'm hoping that's the right stuff and
we'll just take it from there.
Now,
if I remember correctly,
a smarter person would have checked before going
live is that we can
remove the I am not done comment and
then run something on the command line and
it'll tell us if it's correct.
Seems to be the vape of Rustling.
And we've got our first bit of code
here. So what
is this doing?
So here we're here we're constructing a new
vector. Right?
So one of the first things you probably
encounter in Rust is you wanna make an
array of stuff or a list of stuff,
which usually, you know, in Python, you do
with your square brackets.
In Rust, we have those. They're called slices.
They are unowned,
which means you don't actually, like,
get to play with the array.
This is just a usually, they're pointers to
slices.
So vectors are actually owned arrays
or lists or whatever you want to call
them.
So in here, we're actually creating a heap
allocated
owned pointer
to this this memory buffer of at the
what are we filling it with? We're filling
it with I 30 twos.
Yes.
Okay.
Let's
Oh, I don't have Rust links.
Please stand by.
I mean, the Rust compeller doesn't take very
long, so this will be really fast.
Really? I think you're the first person I've
ever heard not complain about the compile time
of Rust. I was complaining about the compile
time of Rust. I think I was just
too subtle with my sarcastic under twins.
Oh, where's oh, am I gonna have to
look at the the read me?
I thought it was just cargo install.
I can't believe I removed it from last
time. There we go. That's what the curl
bash. Nothing ever happened badly from curl bash.
Don't judge me too much, Anna, please.
It's fine.
A curl bash wouldn't work on my machine
at all, so I'm kind of jealous.
Well, yeah, you've got to have derivations and
safety and protections and all of this other
stuff. Right?
Yeah. I don't have a bin bash.
Does
an external chip of, like, fake
ones that link to something else, do I
recall correctly, to try and make it sometimes
work?
Well, idiomatically,
your bash script should be calling user bin
n. Yeah. User bin n. Yeah. So
that's what NextOS supports.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Alright. Well, it's actually gone a lot quicker
than I expected, which is which is good.
It's only got a few more packages left
to build. And then I'm assuming and I
should again know the run Rustling's
move semantics one and it should tell us
that it's failing. I don't think we need
the hint. We'll tell it to try and
run it. And normally what it does, it'll
give us an error message and then that'll
tell us what it actually wants us to
do.
Looking at it, I'm assuming the challenge here
is gonna be
this.
This println vec will be
taking ownership or something and then the push
is gonna fail. I think that's what it's
gonna yell at me for.
Do you think I'm right or am I
wrong already?
I don't know.
Let's I'm looking at it and I'm like,
okay, we've got the failed vac,
return the vector.
So so what's the exercise here? Because I
feel like this might compile.
Well, let's just run it and see. So
we don't need to
we can run Rustling.
Move semantic
one.
Oh, what's the thing?
It was in the top of the
code file. It was in top hint, and
I don't think we need the hint yet.
Oh, yeah. Run my exercise. Okay. So press
things. Run.
Oh, you type like me.
What you mean?
You also mistype all the time. Oh, yeah.
That that's just the rule of being on
a a livestream.
Yeah. Rustler, I'm not running a lot. Yeah.
Because this is the fresh colon of the
Rustlings, and I'm not gonna walk through all
of them to get to this stage.
We'll just use one. But we have our
error message.
Yeah.
So you might notice if you haven't looked
at Rust before, which you have, so that
the error messages are quite
verbose and good.
It does explain what's happening. So we have
a
we've got this VEC one that we've declared
with a let binding, and it's not mutable.
And that's because mutability is opt in in
Rust, which is a very nice thing.
Okay.
So our first error message is just telling
us that we need to make this mutable.
Done. Is that it?
Let's see.
Well, that was easy. So you were almost
right that it would compel if we just
missed immutability. And I'm over here trying to
overthink the ownership of this vector going into
the print function or the print max. So
why do you think we didn't have an
ownership problem here? Just because this fill vac
one
takes a vector and also returns it. Right?
Which line? Sorry?
So if you look at line 18,
the fillvec function
Mhmm.
It takes in an immutable vector, and it
returns a vector. Right? But you see at
line 19, we actually can opt in to
mutability there.
Oh.
Oh, yeah. Because okay. So we're getting a
vector back here that isn't mutable,
but we can actually tell it to become
mutable. So we're like, what what's happening here?
Yeah. So
two different things are happening. Right?
So
to me to push onto a vector,
you you need to mutate it.
So when we made vec zero on line
seven,
and we passed that into the function on
line nine,
so we created it as immutable,
and it arrived into the fillvec function
as an immutable vector.
And on line 19, we opted into mutability
on it, and then we returned it back
on line 25.
So you can see for line 21 through
23, we had mutability.
Oh.
Right?
But before you added that mute on line
nine,
that mutability did not persist past the function
return. Right?
Yes.
That's I think that's the lesson here.
So I'm curious about this line here. Right?
Where we're doing move back equals back. Like,
it's still just one slice in memory. Right?
There's no copy. There's no cloning. This is
just that we take a mutable reference to
it.
Yeah. This is all static. Like, the mute
goes away at compile time.
Can I do that more than once?
Yeah. You can.
Does that mean there's two mutable references to
the same slice?
This one might not work.
Yeah. Okay. See, that that one won't work.
But the first with just one, that's just
basically it's called variable shadowing.
Okay. So because nothing has
mutable ownership of the vector, we can just
take that here, but then we lose the
ability to do that again here.
Now Yeah. We return.
That teaches us one of the fundamental ownership
rules of Rust is that there can only
be one owner
of anything. There are rules?
Yes.
Okay. So there can only ever be one
owner. There's three fundamental rules to ownership in
Rust that
everything only has one owner.
There that owner can give out either
one mutable reference
to the thing
or any number of immutable references to the
thing at any given time.
Okay. Got it. That makes sense.
Yeah. So I think
I understand. Okay. So I understand this. So
this is shadowing
the return drops immutability,
but then we can pick it back up
here.
Right. Okay. And is that just something we're
supposed to know then? Like, when we have
a function and we take mutable ownership of
something and then we return
So if if you think about this modify
this? Could I could I tell it it
returns a mutable reference? No. Yeah. No. That
won't work because
one of the thing like, the fundamental ideas
of Rust that I really appreciate is
the code you're looking at is very localized.
So if I'm looking at a function,
the only thing that I'm looking at in
that function is what's gonna affect the function.
So the signature tells me
that it takes in a vector and it
returns a vector.
But the return type,
it doesn't have, like, mutability or anything
because that would
change how main was working.
And that would make it very confusing to
understand
for the programmer. Right?
Right. Got it.
If
you do want structures with mutability inside of
them without requiring your users to explicitly say
mute,
you can use techniques such as a cell
for that.
Yeah. Again,
that's one of those other constructs of Rust
I have avoided
as much as possible.
So, I mean, if we need to delve
into that today, then we definitely can. But
I I don't we don't need to for
this example right now. Right?
No. Okay.
That really, really helps. I've gotta say it
like that.
I had I had seen lines like this
before. I had just kind of ignored them.
I hadn't really understand how they worked, but
now I understand that, you know, we can
have that one owner. It takes it and
then releases it. So If you took this
code
and you moved it into the main function
instead of the fillVec thing,
and you did let mute VAC equal VAC
and then did your pushes, and then you
went let VAC equal VAC again,
you could just temporarily
opt in to mutability in your main function.
This can be really handy when you're doing
fairly complicated things where you only want temporary
mutability
so that later in the function, you're not
worried about it.
Okay.
Awesome.
Let's move on
to move semantics
two.
Let's get the error message this time and
give ourselves a
hint.
Let's see what we got here. Oh, we
actually have a move now. Oh, there's that
thing that I see all the time. That's
the one.
Oh, my face is covering it. It says
does not implement the copy tree. So yeah,
that's what I'm very familiar with. So that
is on line
line 10 is the move and we're trying
to use it on 13. So
this code looks,
oh, yeah. This function is just pretty much
the same. Right? So Yeah. It's almost the
same as before, but you can see the
print that we're doing is trying to use
the vector that we created and then passed
into fill vac.
Are there
you mean the here?
Yeah. So we create vec zero on line
eight,
and then we we consume vec zero Ah,
right. In line 10, and we give it
to the filvec function,
what filvec returns is a possibly
a completely different vector.
So Okay. The fact that doesn't exist anymore.
Right? Right. Well, after line 10, we have
no guarantee that, yeah, it it's consumed. It's
moved.
So
I think one way we could fix this
is make fill back return
or accept a pointer,
like a reference.
So this is where you do your ampersand.
Right?
So we mark the type as a reference
here.
Yeah. Do we have to also tell it
to pass in a reference? Right.
And now this won't work. Right? Because we're
we've got an immutable
reference,
and we're gonna be trying to make it
mutable. So this is gonna give us problems.
So if we try and compile this, you'll
see a fun error message.
Alright. So we get expected a vac, and
we found reference to a vac.
Oh, this is not the error message I
was expecting, but it's also one.
So fundamentally here, like, if we go back
to the code,
if we're only taking in a reference to
a vector,
we can't return an owned vector.
So just make it a reference too? Right.
But this is still immutable
this whole time. So this is just it's
really not great.
Okay. See, this is giving us error that
you're behind a a normal
immutable reference.
Okay. So I'm assuming that the approach of
passing on a reference to is
potentially
the wrong path. I mean, should we Well,
I guess what we have to consider is
what's the intent here? Is the intent to
create a new vector
and return it, or is the intent to
fill up the vector provided?
Because I think if if we made fillvec
take a mutable reference
to this this collection,
then it it wouldn't need to return
a completely
new vector. Right? It could just mutate the
argument.
Okay. So we want it to be mutable.
Yeah. So we did this,
which means we have to update the signature
here.
Correct. And then we could get rid of
the return type.
Get rid of it?
Would you Sure. Why would that? This doesn't
need this. We don't need to shadow anymore,
right, if we have a We won't need
to do that either. Yeah. This is great.
Okay. Now
would we return
this or would we return the mutable reference
again?
Well, I don't think we need to return
anything. Right? If we're not passing in the
vector, we don't need to get it back.
Oh.
So that?
Yeah. I think that would work.
And then
do have we we forgot about the
Oh, the same one. Yeah. Line 10. Yeah.
So we need to change the VEC one
calls to VEC zero.
Yeah.
But I think that'll work for us.
Oh, jeez.
Alright. So we cannot back viral as mutable
on line 15.
So what happens here?
Well, we've created vec zero as an immutable,
and now we're actually trying to mutate it
twice, which is just it's a no no.
So we're gonna have to make the vec
zero immutable on line eight.
Right? And then we'll have a mutable vec
zero to pass a mutable reference into fillvec.
I mean, could I do
I don't think this will work, but try
it.
See, still
wants a mutable one.
Alright. Okay.
So
we make it mutable from the start.
Now if so let's just I don't know.
We've got a
mutable vector here. Right? So Right. I'm curious.
Do we still need
would that not be passing a mutable reference
though or does that make it Why don't
we why don't we try it? Come on.
Like, the compiler messages are great. We could
find out.
Okay. Let's
I think you will need it there, though.
Alright. Okay. Because you need a mutable thing.
Yeah. Okay. See, it doesn't like us.
So even though it is mutable, when you're
working with function signatures, you always have to
be pretty explicit then.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm
gonna
break that down. So we had two
we had vec zero and vec one, but
what we've found is because we're doing a
mutation and a function and then a mutation
with better function, it's actually probably just best
to have a mutable
reference anyway,
and then Well, we we discovered
that we can't use a value that we've
moved out.
So you can't use after move. So we
had to come up with some way to
keep
the original value
around
or be able to use it later.
And so we just went for mutability.
Okay.
I
don't know if this is a feeling that
I have with the right Rust, but I
I always feel like I try my best
to avoid mutability whenever possible. Is that a
goal, or is that just something I've
stuck in my head for no real rhyme
or reason? This isn't bad code. Right?
No.
I mean,
functional programming tells us you can do a
lot of things without the ability. But fundamentally,
they all end up at IO, right, which
is always mutable. So I I don't think
mutability is bad, but I don't think you
should just blindly opt into mutability on everything.
It
should be something you only add when you
need it. Remember reading a a book when
I was younger. I can't remember what it
was called, but it was like the anatomy
of a computer program or something. And it
was like halfway through the book or three
quarters through the book before they had an
assignment, and they made a note of apologizing
for having an assignment in the book.
Jeez.
It was a really good book about functional
programming and how computer programs work, but the
fact that they apologized for the assignment just
kinda always resonated with me. Not resonated, but
it stuck with me is what I mean.
I don't know. I'm a big fan of
curse code, so I'm I'm fine with that.
That kind of thing.
Alright. Well, again, we're on a second example
and this definitely
helps.
Russell seemed to have a different solution.
So you got a different feel me just
type it in the chat, Russell. We'll move
on to number three just now. I wonder,
like, if we use the hints, will it
tell us how they want to just solve
it or does it
oh, yeah. We get we get some nice
text. So
it's confirming that our vec zero was moved
into the function fillvec when we called it,
which means that it gets dropped. Okay. Dropped
towards not disappeared.
No longer exists. Dropped. Okay. That seems more
technical. We went for the third option here.
Which is to make it fill make it
mutable. Yeah. Okay. So the other options were
make another separate version of the data. So
So would that have been a a clone?
Yeah.
And then option two was we could have
oh, okay. So just do the colon and
the subsequent function. And then Yeah. Okay. So
our our options for filling mutable or clone
the data, which
there are two different ways to solve the
problem and each has a trade off depending
on each individual use case. Rust does a
good job making you feel guilty for doing
heap allocations.
Yeah. I I don't care where I allocate
things. I just want to make to add
new lines to this one.
Oh, wait. What?
No lines for multiple semicolons.
No new line. Okay. Got it. Alright. Let
me see if I can identify the problem
then with this because I'm over two so
far. So we
have a vector. We create the mutable reference
like we did before based on the result
of the fillvec.
We then
because this is the same code. No, no,
no. Okay. So the printvec one push and
then printvec one again.
So
the problem here,
that looks okay to me. I'm gonna run
it. I mean, I know it's not okay,
but I'm gonna say like,
I don't think that the push function
moves anything in
memory?
That should be okay.
Oh, no. Don't read
it.
Oh, it is.
The print has taken the ownership over here.
Yeah. So my trick
is this.
That's what I always do first.
Thanks, Rusty. No. No. I'm glad. Was great.
Yeah. We added new lines now.
Not my fault. It was Rust format or
Rust font depending on how you wanna say
it.
So
I mean, it didn't complain about me passing
these in as a reference to
Yeah. So I'm not sure why
this is telling me
So this is in Philvec though.
Oh.
Yeah.
Right. Okay. So
there's nothing to do with that print statement
at all then. Okay.
We're passing in.
Okay. I got it now.
It's not mutable when we pass it in
here. We're not doing the shadowing and we
cannot do the shadow because
we're not able to add in lines.
Gotcha.
Right. Okay. So Got it.
So we need to be able to make
okay. That's tricky.
Damn you, Rustlings.
I mean, man, even I think but we
tried that with the last one it didn't
really work. So
I I think I think that's a worthwhile
thing to pursue this time.
Okay. So what this
That will imply we have to make vec
zero also mute though.
Would this not just take ownership of it
here?
Well, no.
No.
So we in order to give out a
mutable reference, we need to have a mutable
ownership.
Right. Okay.
Yeah. So we've not added any new lanes.
No. We've only changed them so far. And
I guess this would have to be updated
to do this.
Yeah.
Does it say I can delete lanes?
I mean, that's our solution to the last
one, isn't it? Well, I don't think we
should hold on. Let's play let's play the
game properly. Right? Let's let's try and return
the the mutable pointer to the vector here.
Alright.
Like so.
Yeah. Let's do it.
It worked. Wow.
Alright. I'm confused.
Well, because,
you know, we talked about how you're allowed
to have one mutable reference passed around. Right?
Mhmm.
So
the
in nine, we create the mutable vector.
And in 11,
we get the reference.
Then down in 20,
we accept the argument also as a mutable
reference, and then we return that same reference.
So we're not creating any new reference.
Is there any value
to this approach over, like because, I mean,
we need to move the return previously. Is
that the same code or is it is
it different?
Basically the same.
Okay. This is teaching a slightly different lesson
that, you know, you can return a unique
mutable reference and still work. You can still
get a mutable reference. Right. Okay.
Do you need vec zero after line 11?
Alright. Question from Russell is,
do we need vec zero after lane 11?
I do not think we do.
Well, vec zero will accept will be dropped.
Right? Because vec one now holds the reference.
Well, no. Because it's it's a mutable reference.
Vex zero will still be around.
But doesn't vec one take ownership of it
here?
Like No. Can I I do a print
l n
Yeah? Vec zero?
Yeah.
That's gonna work?
I think so.
Oh, see. Way it's just a formatter.
That message, I know all too well to
Immutable borrow. That's fair.
So what that's saying,
if you look at that, is
on on
line 11,
we took a mutable borrow.
And then we're trying to use
that same thing we have a mutable borough
out for before
we get back that mutable borough.
So if you look at the code again,
because we have VEC one around,
it's not gonna work.
But, like, say you moved line 13 down
to line 20,
and before line on line 19, you put
drop VEC one.
Now that should work because we've explicitly dropped
VEC one, and so we we have the
only ownership over zero.
Tada. I hate computers.
Yeah.
I just assumed
that when
we did this, that this was just dropped
anyway.
Well, because you're taking a mutable reference to
it, main still owns vec zero.
It's just given out a mutable pointer.
And so fun to like, the the big
the big idea here is that if I'm
main and I give out a mutable pointer
to vex zero,
and then, you know,
I'm done and I'm finished,
but I haven't got back that vex zero
pointer.
I can't call drop on it yet until
I get back that pointer that that reference.
Right? Okay. Okay. So it it lets the
compiler
statically track when it will be able to
drop a value.
Okay. I'm getting it.
Yeah. Four, I am gonna I am gonna
get this one though. I feel like I
know
everything there is to know, which of course
is never gonna happen. But
for factor this code, so that instead of
having vec zero and creating a vector and
main, we create an infill vec.
Okay.
So
what we have here is vec zero being
created. It's read only.
And then we get a mutable back.
Wait. Why is this not that argument?
Refracture this code so that instead of having
vec zero,
we it
within fillvec and transfer the
Ah, okay. So basically, this goes away,
and we wanna be able to get a
mutable reference back from field deck.
So does that mean I think we want
ownership.
If you just stop here,
the the thing you're doing here is is
not
like, I know it's not our final code,
but this would never work because
on line 21,
you create
this memory buffer on the heap.
And then on you you return it out
of the function as a mutable reference.
But fundamentally, it won't live long enough.
Oh, I see that message all the time
too. Noise That wouldn't work. Yeah. So
in order to do that, you'd have to
return the own value. Yeah. So really what
we want is vec equals
Yeah. Like vec new or whatever.
Well, I guess it would guess a tape,
but I've I've taped it there. So Yeah.
Oh, no. But it would be vague.
Okay.
So then we have this is not mutable,
so I'm assuming we still need this. We
push push, push and then this returns.
So does this mean here because it's dropped
from fillvec, the vec one is now the
owner of this?
Yeah. So
at the end of the fillvec call, when
you return the vector,
the main becomes the new owner of that
that variable. Yeah. Okay. So
that should work. There we go. Tada.
Okay.
I get it. Kinda.
Good.
Alright. We've got one more.
Number five. Took me a long time to
search and internalize some of these rules, so
don't feel bad.
Oh, this one looks fun.
Stars everywhere.
Okay. So make me compile without adding, removing,
or changing any lanes. What?
Make me compile without changing any code.
Is that what it's doing?
Interesting.
Okay. So we have okay. Let's let's go
through this lane by lane because I I
don't understand this code. So on lane nine,
we create a mutable
variable called x, which equals
an integer.
Line 10, we
have y,
which is a mutable reference
to
that.
And then on lane 11, we've got z
which is a
mutable reference to a d referenced y which
would be x. So
I mean, that's not legal. Right?
Oh, let's try and and build this.
Okay.
Yeah. That's fair.
So this is saying that we cannot use
star y because it was mutable. Yeah. That's
what I thought. Good.
Because this is a mutable reference to x,
and this is essentially doing the same thing.
Right? Star y is x. Is that right?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
So so how do we fix this if
we can't change the code? I don't understand.
Make me compile without adding,
removing,
or changing.
That cannot be right.
So do we have to add stuff like
around main?
But it says we can't change any
should we have the I don't understand it.
In main. Yeah. Maybe.
Okay. Carefully reason about the range in which
each mineral reference
is in vogue.
Does it help to update the value of
Oh, oh, gosh. It says you can reorder
them, which is definitely changing them.
But that's changing the lanes.
I know.
Okay. So now with this this new knowledge
that we can reorder them, let's think about
this.
Okay. So
we know that when we have y,
we have a mutable the the unique mutable
reference to x. Right? Correct. Yes.
And when we have z, we also have
a unique mutable reference
to to x. Yeah. So I think if
we reordered it so that we did not
have z existing while we mutated y,
it might work.
Like that?
I think so.
That was easy. I knew it. Yeah. Yeah.
So
this only works. I don't know if I'm
yeah. Let let me try and articulate this.
This only works because we don't use y
anymore. Is that right?
That's correct.
Like, this one now cause it to fail
again,
I think. Yeah.
Well, that and my inability to macro.
Well, that still works.
Really?
Dog.
Oh, but we're not mutating it. Right? So
Yeah. That's fair.
There we go. Okay.
Well, that that that wasn't the right error.
But, yeah, came with the no.
That was you have to dereference the thing.
But doing this would create a create a
new integer. Oh, yeah. This is because these
these are fixed size integer. Okay. Yeah. Okay.
These are these these integers implement copy.
So
Yeah.
And Rust doesn't care about copy.
Well, copy implied some things very cheap to
make a copy of. So
Yep.
Alright.
That really helped my understanding.
Good.
So we've got around
fifteen minutes left. Will we will we tackle
lifetimes? I
don't I don't think we'll get that far,
but I'd love to chat about them a
bit. So I wanna go through that exercise
that you you did with me when I
was looking for help last week. Oh, no.
Okay. I don't know if I can remember
it, but sure.
Yeah. You have to remember all off the
top of your head. Go.
Okay.
No. Alright. Let me create
I'll just say Rawkode RS.
So
let's have a function,
main
print ln.
This is about as good as my Rust
gets.
Sure.
Cargo
run.
Really? It's gonna compare all of that for
hello
just because I'm in that directory.
Interesting.
Yeah. That's annoying. That's annoying. But I should've
used Rusty.
I don't know if that would've worked.
I guess, only has to do it once.
Oh, does that not work?
Well, that doesn't run it. How can I
just run a fail?
I think that that will have created a
binary in your directory you can run.
Yeah. To run the Rawkode.
Alright.
Okay. Can I not just tell it to
interpret and run the file? You're not really
supposed to, like, just ad hoc run Rust
files. So
I'm changing those rules today. Jeez.
So,
yeah, the exercise that you walked me through
last time, which has been infinitely beneficial to
me, and I think we should share it
with people, is that
I have ignored
lifetimes
for as long as I've been writing Rust
because I just I really don't really want
to worry about it.
Yeah. But the thing that you kind of
may help me realize is that even if
the lifetimes aren't in my code,
they are still
here. They still exist and we we can
make them explicit.
And and just that process
really helped me understand it.
So
I'm not sure if we need to type
new code or if we Yeah. We probably
will, right, won't we?
So should we have a
new function that just prints out? Here,
let's let's do like,
let's make a string.
Rawkode.
It's in here. And
we can print out that string. Right?
And then,
like, this is basically what we were doing
before. Do
do the thing.
Yeah. And my
awkward understanding of string and string and string
and string,
but just no much better now because of
this. Yeah.
So
wrong.
I don't really know what I'm doing here,
but we're going to do it.
Yeah, so this will give me
the fundamental.
We were talking about string and string and
STR. Right?
Yeah. That was right. Yeah. Yeah. So
if you have a string,
which would be this
in here,
you have ownership
of a memory buffer
of the, like, unsigned eight bit integers.
Now
if I was to
do, like, as STR here
so that I got in
some STR type, which I'm sure a lot
of people are used to seeing in Rust.
That
is unknown.
It's just a reference
to one of those same
memory buffers.
So
you can think of a reference to a
string as an STR
with
a lifetime
shorter than the string.
So
when we talk about lifetimes,
if I made some string processing function,
like split,
took in
one of these
string STRs,
which is one of these unknown slices
So I didn't own the memory.
It would essentially
be doing
this where I have this lifetime,
which is just a generic type. You know,
if you're you've written a lot of Rust,
you might be used to seeing generics like
this.
Lifetimes are just another type, basically.
What's that saying
is just that
the x str
has the same lifetime as the function's call.
So you can think of
starting
here
and then ending
here.
So when I pass in the STR up
here,
that that reference
will only be alive until line 13
Okay.
Because I'm not I'm not assigning it here.
So if I had, like, let
ref
thing equal this,
and I did return
that same STR,
it would persist all the way through to
here.
Right. Okay. Yeah.
So there's a big difference between an unowned
type and an unowned type.
References,
as we saw in wrestlings,
allow
us to work with them. But when you
get into scenarios where you references of references,
lifetimes are really powerful because,
you know, in this case, this is obvious.
You know, if you give me a string
and I return to you one of these
sorry. If you give to me an STR
and I return to you an STR,
they pretty much have to be of the
same lifetime.
Because if you give me unknown memory and
I give you a pointer to unknown memory
that's within that unknown memory, I can't do
anything other than promise that it will be
valid for as long as the unknown memory
is valid.
But let's say we were writing a split,
so we we are actually splitting up this
this
this unknown slice.
We might have some, you know, set
of
subsets of this STR. So we might return
a back of
STR instead.
It still all have the same lifetime, so
it doesn't really matter.
But I've probably written very broken code here,
so I hesitate
anyone trying to run it.
But, you know, lifetimes Sorry. Let me go.
Go ahead. I was gonna say, one of
the weird situations I always seem to get
myself into, and I've never really understood it,
has been like I write a function,
and it tells me that the value doesn't
live long enough to be returned.
So usually, that's because you're doing something like
you're trying to return a reference
to,
say I did let a equal
And then I return a. This would actually
be quite valid,
because
the let a equals thing there
is a static string
gets actually written into the binary.
So if I was to run string mean
that is
this?
Yeah. That's that. Right. So
the static means is that it's gonna be
alive for the whole time.
So, like, this is completely valid that
you could make it
like that. This is a valid function, and
it's fine. Okay. But the moment I try
and do
let's say I do this and I do
ref of a
like that.
And then I try and return ref of
a.
Because I'm trying to return a reference
to some memory that is only alive during
the function call, this owned buffer,
Mhmm.
That value is not going to be around
at the end after the end of the
function call. So in main,
when I called this up here,
one thing like this. Yep.
X in this case would be an invalid
pointer. Right?
Okay. So can we make this explicit? I
wanna see if I understand this correctly. Yeah.
We're saying all functions already have a lifetime.
Where where does that go?
Is it Yeah. So this is like an
a?
Yeah. So like you could think of all
functions having a lifetime.
Then Which means that this here
is lifetime of
a.
I don't even know what I'm like, that's
reference. Would that have the same lifetime? You
could think of this
say
say we're doing something really complicated with string
processing, you might actually see something like
this.
No. I don't like it.
Yeah. So this is about sub lifetimes.
And what this is saying is essentially, like,
all of the lifetimes
b
are shorter than or or, like, within the
realm of
a.
And, yeah, you don't like that, but that's
fundamentally what's happening. It's like, this is some
some random lifetime called who knows what.
That's a sub lifetime of a.
Right. Okay.
Yeah. I think I I need to do
some reading on life science. And I I
based actually now just on where this going,
I feel like this life science are probably
an entire episode on their own with like,
I don't even know sub life times were
a thing. Sub life times.
Yeah.
Well, I you know, we could also talk
about
ARC and RC and how boxes work. There's
lots of fun to be had.
So boxes are just something that I've only
just started using since I've been working on
Hong Kong Triad just because I have so
many different, like,
subtypes on enums
and I I kinda need to them to
pass those around. So I feel dragged
into learning that, but they're slowly starting to
make sense. And I and I understand it.
It's like we have this thing of size
and a box is a way to pass
around. Like, I think it's just a pointer
to it. Is that right? Yeah. So turning
something into a box puts it on the
heap.
And then so if you do like a
boxed in
trait,
that just basically is putting a pointer to
the v table on the on the heap.
Okay.
I think what we'll do, just given the
time and how much more stuff we could
potentially go into, is I would just chat
with you later and we'll maybe see if
you're up for doing another episode where we
look at all those other cool that I
have no idea about.
But that
was really helpful for me. Like, just going
through those most semantic things and having, you
know, your experience help guide us and and
just even explaining it all really, really helps.
And I hope that other people got value
from that as well. So Yeah. I had
a lot of fun. Next time, you'll have
to let me make some some good examples
too.
No. That's not a lie on this show.
No. No. All examples must be terrible, terrible,
terrible. Although your examples were definitely perfectly fine.
I brought the terrible.
Thank
you for I don't know. I wrote some
pretty trash code there.
Well, I think when it's in the name
of explaining concepts, that that is perfectly valid.
Perfectly valid code.
And we got a thank you from the
Nina as well.
I will reiterate that. Thank you so much
for taking time out of your day and
walking me through this. Like I said, that
was really, really, really helpful.
Looking forward me.
And I'm looking forward to hopefully having another
episode. And your dog is looking mighty cute
in the background. Yeah.
Well, feel free to connect with me on
Twitter or whatever, and happy to say hi
to all your folks. Awesome. Thanks so much.
Alright. Have a a great day, and I
will speak to you again soon. Thank you.
Bye.